to me more has been stirring up a big
bus to about her explosive new tell-all
and noun de Mia's facing the camera for
the first time since her bombshells
began to drop from where I started to
what I've experienced where I've been
like how did I get here if there is one
thing we've learned so far from inside
out
it's that de mie is a survivor you
growing up it is she told Diane Sawyer
her mother was an alcoholic suicidal and
unleashed the ultimate betrayal
the details are hard to hear but Jimmy
says when she was fifteen years old and
older acquaintances raped her he then
asked cruelly quote how does it feel to
be [ __ ] by your mother for five
hundred dollars do you believe she sold
you in my deep heart no I don't think it
was a straightforward transaction but
she still did give him the access in
1982 Demi landed her first big role on
General Hospital she played the iconic
Luke Spencer's new love interest why
don't we have a seat in the lack that
promises will be very painless behind
closed doors de mie says she was
overwhelmed and tamed her fears with
alcohol et first met to me during that
time in her life I'm 19 I just I just
turned 90 she told us about stepping
into the legendary Jeanie Francis's
shoes I feel that I'm gonna like that
person right off the screen because I'm
her plus more
they'll have an off switch I don't have
the thing that says this is enough by
the way Demi Moore was nominated for but
lost an Emmy in 1997 for the TV movie if
these walls could talk
[Music]